[Music]
it is 6 26 on your wednesday morning wow
we got a big response to that viewer
email about expired tags the other day
you might have missed it when patrick
wrote that the abundance of cars on the
road with expired tags is driving him
crazy while among the replies from dude
there are probably as many vehicles with
expired or no place as there are covid
cases in this town i'm tired of being in
the minority doing what they're supposed
to do and following the law from anthony
sounds like viewers need to be minding
their business who emails to snitch on
somebody not having tagged and from todd
most also have no plates that means no
insurance ptolem and fighter
yeah all kinds of reactions there now
law enforcement has said in the past
that their priorities are
on other crimes on our roads but we're
checking to see if they've updated their
responses thanks again to patrick to
dude anthony and todd for riding you're
welcome to weigh in too and buckle up
drive carefully put on that phone here's
the address if something's driving you
crazy traffic eight at eightnewsnow.com